[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zum tennis
welt heute gibt es eine halloween torte
ihr könnt die torte aber auch zu
bereiten wenn ihr jetzt nicht unbedingt
halloween feiert aber samira el und ich
haben uns da was ausgedacht die mädels
sind dann auch beim dekorieren mit dabei
aber ich habe mir gedacht die böden und
die creme das bereite ich jetzt kurz
alleine vor dann geht es ein bisschen
schneller denn die konzentration lässt
dann natürlich auch recht schnell nach
wenn sie jetzt beim ganzen back prozent
dabei sind dauert alles länger und
deswegen bereitet alles vor und bei der
deko sind die mädels dann mit dabei ich
mache jetzt einen richtig schönen mandl
rührteig dass es so ein basis rezept aus
meinem oder von einem kanal dürft ihr
auch gerne mal vorbeischauen ich habe da
ganz viele grundrezepte die könnt ihr
miteinander kombinieren ihr könnt auch
ein biskuit backen oder ein wiener boden
was immer er möchte ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach den ersten tag und dann mache
ich aber drei torten jeder von uns
bekommt eine torte und die backe ich
dann gleich noch im nachgang wird den
teig nämlich 350 gramm zucker etwas
tonka wanka und eine prise salz jeweils
150 gramm sonnenblumenöl und milch in
225 gramm mehl und backpulver oder ihr
nehmt back mail und 100 gramm gemahlene
mandeln wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr
gerne auch noch lebensmittelfarbe
benutzen falls es wirklich so bisschen
halloween style sein soll ich würde
einfach verpasste in gelb und rot noch
dazu nehmen damit ich ein schönes orange
habe das machen jetzt ganz kurz im
schnelldurchgang also eier zucker
salz und
tom kha
das muss ich noch öffnen
irgendwie rührschüssel geben ihr könnt
auch manuelle extrakt verwenden aber
tonka passt schon auch sehr gut zum
schokoladigen torte dann die zutaten
etwa fünf bis zehn minuten gut verrühren
bist du schön schaumig sind
[Musik]
wenn die eier masse dann so aussieht
jetzt die zwei flüssigkeiten dazugeben
und gerne an dieser stelle auch die
lebensmittelfarbe
also ein bisschen rot bisschen gelb
[Musik]
und kurz vorsichtig einrühren
jetzt kennt ihr das mehl mit dem
backpulver vermischen und dazu sieben
oder beim bak mail einfach direkt dazu
geben das muss man nicht leben dann noch
die mandeln die machen den teig schön
saftig und die zutaten werden nicht nur
noch ganz kurz eingerührt und ganz
vorsichtig
[Musik]
ok
orange ist schon so eine halloween farbe
muss ich sagen schön knackig und was ihr
nicht vergessen dürfe die farben die
stärken noch ein bisschen nach also die
zehn echt ein bisschen nach hinten wenn
sie warm werden das heißt wenn es jetzt
noch nicht knallig orange ist keine
sorge durchs becken wird es knapp und
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal 2 back
ringe mit backpapier eingeschlagen denn
der teig ist relativ flüssig kann also
ein bisschen auslaufen das sind jetzt
kleine 15 zentimeter ringe ich hatte ein
bisschen kleiner als 15 eingestellt
damit wir auch schöne hohe torten
bekommen und jetzt auf zwei aufteilen
das bad dann schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
schön vorgeheizt und während der bauzeit
kann ich die anderen würden vorbereiten
jetzt habe ich alle böden gebacken und
sie sind auch schon schön abgekühlt
dafür gibt's jetzt noch eine leckere
schokoladencreme ich werde die
schokoladencreme gleich auch noch
schwarz einfärben das ist einfach so ein
bisschen mehr halloween like wird ihr
könnt die verpasste aber auch weglassen
und einfach nur eine schoko creme machen
dafür nämlich 100 gramm sahne etwas
schwarze lebensmittel verpasste 100
gramm zartbitterschokolade
150 g weiche butter 50 gramm puderzucker
150 g frischkäse und 30 gramm cacau das
ist jetzt die menge die ihr braucht für
den mittleren kuchen und ich werde
einfach so machen dass ich eben meine
app eine kuchen größe an gebe es ist ja
alles der gleiche kuchen unterschiedlich
groß und ihr könnt dann eben einstellen
oder reinschreiben welche größe ihr
haben wollt und dann spuckt euch meine
app die richtigen zutaten aus ich mache
das jetzt hier für die 15 tatorte aber
ich habe noch eine 20er und zähne so
eine ganz kleine mini karte für die ela
okay los geht's zuerst wird die sache
kurz aufgekocht
und weil die schwarze farbe intensiver
wird wenn sie warm ist gebe ich jetzt
die schwarze farbe hier direkt mit rein
in die saane dann ist es schwarz einfach
intensiv schwarz
und jetzt kommen hier die schoko jobs
mit rein also die zarte schokolade
und einfach kurz schmelzen lassen
ok so eine garage hatte ich auch nicht
interessant schön rühren bis alles
geschmolzen ist und dann umfeld damit
die garage also die schokoladenmasse
einfach gut abkühlen kann ich stelle
jetzt gleich zur seite auf dem ipad
damit so ein bisschen schneller geht und
kann in der zeit schon mal butter und
puderzucker schön cremig rühren
das wird ein richtig richtig tolle creme
die wird nicht so schwer wie buttercreme
aber butter sollte hier schon ein
bisschen rein damit ich die torten
schöne glatt bekommen die auch fast
werden denn die deko später die brauchen
einen schönen festen untergrund
jetzt das ganze kurz cremig rühren
[Musik]
den frischkäse und das kakaopulver
einrühren und dann warte ich kurz darauf
bis die
schokoladenmasse kalt ist also die muss
nicht ganz kalt sein nicht kühlschrank
kalt sondern einfach abgekühlt sein und
dann kann ich sie eindringen wenn ich
jetzt so heiß ein roter schmilzt die
butter und dann ist es ganz so volumen
wieder weg
[Musik]
und so lange kann ich jetzt schon mal
alle böden herauslösen die sollten auf
jeden fall ganz abgekühlt sein und am
besten ist so war immer wenn er die
kuchen backt abkühlen lassen und dann
noch mal in den kühlschrank gestellt
dann lassen sie sich besser
durchschneiden also sowas kann man auch
ganz gut im am tag davor machen spart
man sich ein bisschen zeit und hat nicht
so viele wartezeiten dazwischen und so
kann man sich das backen schon whistler
erleichtern
[Musik]
und dann am besten mit der torten säge
oder mit einem torten messer einmal
durchschneidungen sind
dies
der richtige allen
ich glaube das wird die mädels glücklich
machen
[Musik]
die schwarze schoko sahne ist abgekühlt
die wir jetzt hier noch rein gerührt ich
hoffe ich habe genug schwarz dass die
creme um wirklich wirklich schwarz wird
und weil das ganze jahr halloween torte
wird habe ich schon mal den tolga
losgeschickt um meine bachelor box zu
holen er ist bestimmt gleich zurück aber
ich will jetzt erst mal kurz die creme
denn ich möchte das ganze auch füllen
mit süßigkeiten ich meine sonst hast
keine halloween potter hermine ist schon
immer so süßes oder saures und genau so
müssen süßes oder saures auch reinpacken
ok drückt mir die daumen
[Musik]
und damit das ganze noch mal intensiver
schwarz wird gebe ich jetzt rot rein das
nimmt so ein bisschen das einzige weg
uns im gras worten zu sagen
[Musik]
oktober kommen hast du das
auch so einiges
ich habe nämlich eine riesen eine riesen
hitler auswahl zeigt
sie passen auch gut die dino krallen
sauer wenn man normale hit she's
schnüre
saure kraken habe
okay wir nehmen sie krakenarme saure
dino krallen dann lassen wir die drachen
zunge weg und neben noch normale hippies
perfekt
danke aber schon die gleise
ja das ist gut
also dann geht's los mit dem befüllen
der torte ich freue mich ich nehme jetzt
einen garching bord auf meine dreh
platte
dann den unteren boden
erste schicht buttercreme das fach
spielt gefällt mir das sieht hammer aus
und jetzt füllung ich nehme auch noch
diese
white christmas zu als chronisch das ist
über zehn überzogener keks eigentlich
mit schokolade überzogen an krebs dann
habe ich das mit dabei
ich darf mir dabei
nehmen die sauren krakenarme
was saures was süßes was blaues was
alles auf das war hochzeit
ich muss sagen der halloween trend der
der war mal da und die letzten jahre
habe ich auch gesehen so die
nachbarskinder die kam dann auch
tatsächlich an unserer tür ich bin
halloween grundsätzlich nicht zu hause
nicht ginge
denn wir sind ja dann auch unterwegs mit
den kindern und das hat ja irgendwie das
hat er nichts nun glauben oder so oder
keine ahnung was zu tun das ist einfach
für die kinder und spaß sich zu
verkleiden und früher war es schon mal
was gläubiges hatte ja was mit dem
ersten november zu tun mit allerheiligen
dass ihr nämlich ich glaube aus irland
kommt das ganze sind nämlich die armen
dann von haus zu haus gezogen und haben
gesagt können wir bitte was süßes nicht
was süßes aus aber können ein bisschen
geld zu essen haben und wir beten dann
für die verstorbenen und darum ging es
eigentlich und dann wird das ganze in
ein meer einfach so einem trend
umgewandelt und wird eben halloween
aber der ursprungsgedanke war eigentlich
schon schöner
und jetzt ist es einfach so was
gesellschaftlich ist aber eher für die
kinder finde ich gut die habe ich noch
mit drin und noch die dino krallen und
dann kommt einfach der nächste boden
drauf und so wird die komplette torte
gefüllt
[Musik]
vielleicht noch ein kleiner tipp für
euch falls ihr torten nicht schön gerade
füllen könnt ohne ring nehmt einfach
einen tortenring außen rum dann geht es
für ein bisschen einfacher und wenn ihr
merkt die creme ist noch zu weich stellt
kurz im kühlschrank aber mit ringen
außen herum geht es viel besser dann ist
sie immer sofort gerade wenn man da
jetzt nicht so viel übung drin hat
[Musik]
das sieht gut aus also die zwei oberen
di lasso zweck man könnte ja auch noch
gerade schneiden aber ich finde von der
höhe her passt es so schon perfekt und
jetzt werde ich schon mal die oberfläche
noch bisschen bestreichen und die torte
und kühl stellen werden gleich nochmal
creme zu bereiten und die anderen zwei
auffüllen und dann geht es gleich weiter
und ich zeige euch wie man diese torte
richtig klappt bekommt aber erst mal
muss sie durch kühlen ihr seht schon die
wackelt und dafür hat sich jetzt auch im
ringen
mit folie
aus den minis kann ich sogar zwei
kreuzchen machen
schön
diese farben sind einfach krass
süßes oder saures und
drauf jetzt habe ich alle törtchen
fertig
die decke ich jetzt ab dann kommen sie
einen kühlschrank
bis morgen ich werde die creme oder bis
später ich weiß noch nicht jedenfalls
müssen die jetzt erstmal gut durch
kühlen und danach kann ich sie alle
glatt streichen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der spaßige teil nämlich die
dekoration spät die torte gleich auf
eine tortenplatte setzen die anderen
zwei habe ich auch schon gestrichen ich
habe mich marshmallows und schmelz die
kurz in der mikrowelle bis sie sich
aufplustern dann weiß ich nämlich dass
die geschmolzen sind
[Musik]
vorsichtig sein nicht verbrennen
richtig heiß
jetzt könnt ihr hier die master gut
durch noch nicht anfassen dieses
wirklich noch zu heiß da würdet ihr euch
jetzt verbrennen
ich hab so ein bisschen rührend kühlt
sich weiter ab und man sieht jetzt schon
wie es schön fäden zieht und es werden
gleich die spinnweben
ich mag keine spinnen und das echt sowas
ist zu garten mag
[Musik]
wenn es dann ein bisschen abgekühlt ist
okay jetzt wird ein bisschen schmutzig
ihr nehmt jetzt das in die hand oh
ja ich glaube das wird den kindern spaß
machen und
zieht jetzt spinnweben und
setzt die um die torte okay ich brauche
aber noch ein bisschen mehr
und das dürfen jetzt gleichsam johanna
ok einfach auseinander ziehen und so
dran kleben einfach kreuz und quer
man muss halt immer so die perfekte
konsistenz abwarten
[Musik]
ich bin spiderman
ist schon eklig aber ich mag
das richtig hofft rossi
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sein denken
[Musik]
und zwar
so spyder meinem film und sparen
[Musik]
so gott hilf mir
nein
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das war ja
und jetzt was kann man am ende drohen
nun fertig ist
in serie
[Musik]
all diese spinne habt ihr die aus dem
rest kuchen gemacht
[Musik]
was sagt ihr zum anschnitt der torte
nochmal wie kohli aussieht
ist das eine halloween grusel und
das stimmt wir haben das video
vorgedreht
cholera kann man probieren mal
ich habe auch ritchies da drin in der
torte
die saure krakenarme
diesmal richtig tot
ich glaube er war auch
richtig saftig
aromatisch
der hintern ist nackt sogar die spinne
sieht im inneren so aus also richtig
coole idee mit eurer spinne hier
droht
die torte ist echt gut nicht also die
dürfte jetzt über nacht einmal
durchziehen die ist echt perfekt die
bösen sind saftig die creme ist gut ich
hoffe ich keine schwarzen szene
voll gut
und hat spaß gemacht die spinnweben zu
machen
war schon eine klebrige angelegenheit
oder
ok ich glaube mehr kommen die ziemlich
raus denn die torte ist sehr lecker und
dem mädels haben hunger oft orte also
probiert die torte gerne mal aus das
rezept gibt es wie immer in meiner app
oder auch sei dies
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
und das heißt auch gar nicht so schwer
torte füllen bestimmt haben auch
diamanten drauf dekoriert
okay sie die zucker schrift aus als
hätte die spinne geblutet wow jetzt ist
richtig halloween
ok teams
mitteilen die mit den anderen
[Musik]